de hecho yo me salí de la prepa dos
veces ambas en el primer año y cuando
regrese después me pusieron en clases de
nivel bajo de matemáticas y ciencias
porque estaba muy atrasado después
descubrí khan academy y logré saltarme
dos años de matemáticas solo por usar el
sitio
vine a la escuela y tomé el examen junto
con otros alumnos que habían tomado la
clase todo el año y saqué la
calificación más alta o la segunda más
alta de todo el grupo
así que khan academy realmente cambió
todo el curso de mi vida
porque sin él creo que nunca me hubiera
inspirado para aprender y para amar las
matemáticas y las ciencias
al final me gradué como el mejor de la
generación y luego entré a princeton
donde estudió ciencias de la computación
y me apasiona muchísimo aprender sobre
computadoras matemáticas y ciencia y sin
khan academy creo que estas cosas no me
importaría como me importan ahora
así que muchísimas gracias a todos en
khan academy y al equipo
por favor sigan haciendo el trabajo que
hacen porque de verdad están cambiando
vidas